all right ariel is with us in texas hi
ariel how are you
hey dave how are you thanks for taking
my call sure what's up
okay so i have a question my husband and
i we just had baby two
in december um we found out about you in
october and we have about
90k in debt i haven't been working since
last march so i'm kind of preparing to
go back into making money we've been
living off my husband's income
about 75 um and so that covers our
expenses and
since we're getting rid of some payments
this coming month we'll have a little
bit more to put towards our debt
but i'm debating now if i should go back
into like a corporate field
have a background in project management
et cetera i could probably make around
70 80k a year
versus um i have an opportunity to
partner with a gym and personal training
there
at work there is a personal trainer well
i'll be doing a mix of building my own
clientele along with leads that come
into the gym
but it'll probably take me a longer bit
of time to ramp up to
that kind of equal level of income you
know because i'll be having a bill
myself
um so how many personal trainers at that
gym make 80k
i mean how many of them how many
um it's a small blue private boutique
gym so
how many personal trainers at any gym in
your area do you know that make
80k probably none
i don't it's just what i really
care about you know and so i'm debating
this and
yeah okay so i don't mind if i don't
mind if you want to do it because you
care about it
but don't lie to yourself because you
just told me you're going to make 80k
and you're not
i figure after a few years with the good
what different streams of income coming
in from fitness and health
maybe starting the online program you
might build a business that does that
but one-on-one personal training has a
logistical problem you only have so many
hours in the day
and it's hard to charge five x of what
everybody else charges
you gotta be really good to do that i
mean it's unusual but some people do
i mean they're not saying nobody does it
but i just don't want you
i want you to do this realistically and
say okay
i'm gonna go live my dream the first
year i'm gonna make 30 and the next year
i'm gonna make 50 and then if i can
build my business and have some
alternative product lines
i might get it up to 80 or even 180 i
don't know
that that's possible i mean you develop
some supplemental lines and you do some
other stuff
lots of people in the fitness world have
done that and it made serious bank
yeah that's how that takes exactly that
takes that's building a business that's
not just personal training
and so i'm okay with that but you're not
going to do that on 20 hours a week
either
okay so what is it you're gaining
because you're going to be working
just as much as you would in corporate
america maybe you got some flexibility
in your times
but you're going to have to put in the
hours if you're going to get the results
agreed
absolutely okay so you're not doing this
so you can spend more time with the kids
no it won't be that yeah it's more so
just doing
work that i feel like won't that that
will energize me more so
yeah and that you own and that you own
okay i'm all right with that
yeah what we're saying is is for you to
open your own business
that has a 30 050 080 000 trajectory
over the next three years is going to
cost your family a little bit of money
on the front end hopefully you'll make
it up on the back end
and it's going to slow down the pace at
which your family gets out of debt
and if you all are willing to do that
and make that sacrifice i'm not going to
yell at you for that
i'll support you i'll support you not
what i thought you would say
yeah well i'm about you getting out of
debt but you know
yeah you know if you told me you could
make 300 000 in corporate america i tell
you to shut up and go do it for two
years and
get yourself out of debt and have a pile
of money to open your business with
right
i'd go use that for the bank but the
difference the swing in this
is not over the next five years is not
that dramatic
if you go ahead and build your business
but don't lie to yourself and say you're
going to do enough workouts with
individuals to pull 80 grand in
do the numbers on that take about the
number of hours of the day how many
times you'd have to do a workout
and how many clients you'd have to
acquire to cause that to happen
logistically the math isn't going to
work out for you the business proform is
going to break down your project manager
you know how to do that
yeah i have i have and i look at it now
based on the amount that they charge at
this particular gym
i will be looking at anywhere from like
80 to 100 bucks a session so if i get
about 15
clients to have about 15 sessions a week
i can make possibly that 60.
yeah that's what i'm thinking about but
again that's what i'm thinking and
that's that's working a lot because
that's working a lot
yeah because you got client acquisition
in here outside of those sessions yeah
you have to have
the you're not only producing the widget
the actual service you've got to do
client acquisition too
absolutely you what you just described
is a 40-hour week
absolutely yeah that's what i'm thinking
okay good we're on the same page
you can do this i'm sending you a copy
of christy wright's book business
boutique equipping women to make money
doing what they love
and we'll help you do that so yeah go
with it but but let's
let's just use lots of uh clear glasses
no rose-colored stuff
right so real clear we around here we
always use jim collins phrase the
the last ten percent of truth which is
the ugly stuff
if talk about the last ten percent of
truth i'm not gonna lie to myself i'm
not gonna exaggerate this i'm not gonna
try to blow hot air i'm just gonna get
her done and be realistic about my
projections
good stuff